you're not keen on anywhere where
there's a language barrier okay
i was in spain um and i was in a
restaurant and i don't want to go into
too much detail but i needed to yeah
drop the kids off at the pool
i went to flush didn't work flushed
again six seven times i tried to get it
down james would not go
so i'm going to do the right thing i'm
not just going to do a hit and run and
leave it here
i'll go out and tell someone that
there's a problem with their facility so
i went out into the restaurant i found
the waiter unfortunately he didn't speak
a word of english i didn't speak any
spanish so i ended up having
ended up having the kind of gesture to
this man yes could you just come here no
leave the malaria just follow me i
ushered him in to the toilet
i pointed at my poo i went to flush it
went down straight away
[Applause]